des candidatures qui pourrait changer la
donne celle de l'ancien président henri
konan-bédié et de pascal affi n'guessan
deux grandes figures ivoirienne dont
l'entrée en course pour la
présidentielle pourrait troubler celle
du président alassane ouattara
henri konan-bédié 86 ans ancien homme
fort du pays a fait de la repentance son
slogan
sa carrière a été marquée par un exil
forcé de deux années à la fin de son
mandat à la suite d'un coup d'état
militaire en 1999 cette année
nous permettra de reconstruire une côte
d'ivoire réconciliée avec elle même
une fois deux voies de la paix de la
tolérance du dialogue du développement
candidature également de pascal affi
n'guessan ancien premier ministre de
laurent gbagbo aujourd'hui à 67 ans il
se présente en sauveur de son mentor et
de la patrie nous rassemblement pour la
retenant démocratique le rassemblement
pour mettre fin aux souffrances endurées
par notre peu de rassemblements pour
permettre aux clients à laurent gbagbo
charles blé goudé dure entre les plombs
calme en côte d'ivoire au lendemain
étendu en temps parce que leur retour
sera le premier acte politique que je
poserai pour sceller la réconciliation
nationale laurent gbagbo condamné par la
justice ivoirienne à 20 ans de prison
pour avoir saisi des liquidités de la
banque centrale des états d'afrique de
l'ouest en 2010 et 2011
condamnation également pour l'ancien
président du parlement
guillaume soro notamment pour recels de
détournement de deniers publics
tous deux rêvent encore de se hisser à
la tête du pays dès cette année radié
des listes électorales ils ont annoncé
leur décision de déposer malgré tous
leurs dossiers pour la présidentielle
face à ces candidatures de l'opposition
alassane ouattara brigue un troisième
mandat controversé un choix qui
découlent du décès de son successeur
désigné le premier ministre amadou
coulibaly un vide juridique
un changement de constitution en 2016 et
le président ivoirien est revenu sur sa
promesse de laisser la place à près de
manda les sommets fait
j'invite nos concitoyens et je sais que
nos concitoyens se souviendra une paire
en 4 bilan exceptionnel
cette dernière en bilan qui reste
toutefois contesté par une partie de la
population mais aussi deux de ses
anciens ministres devenu candidat
écoutez l'analyse de rodrigues connaît
sociologue analystes politiques
chercheurs à l'african security secteur
network
ben si nous faisons une analyse des
rapports de force actuellement sur
l'espace politique
il reste que l'acteur alassane ouattara
reste un acteur en pole position pour
cette élection
ce qui ne veut pas dire que ce qui ne
veut pas dire que non plus qu'il qui la
remportera si l'on analyse il a été en
posture de la fabrique les règles du jeu
électoral
ensuite il à l'appareil d'état et il
s'entend également le monopole de la de
la violence physique légitime ce qui
reste un des unes des ressources très
importantes
ensuite la capacité également d'utiliser
les les finances et entre les impôts des
suppositions
elle a une bonne relation plus ou moins
avec les acteurs internationaux
à mon avis le positionne aux côtés des
acteurs sérieux pour ces élections dès